how long have you guys been together
oh that's why you're so sad how are you
guys pretended to be friends
the window is still open dude
where the is he it's a Saturday
night and you're in a dark basement with
another dude I got a boyfriend I don't
think he knows this guy would never do
that to you look how sweet this guy is I
don't like your boyfriend that guy sucks
where is he right now this piece of
that's not that far he could have got
here yesterday hung out all day been
here with you right now
because he's a better man
what does he do
yeah I bet he land a lot of wood around
[Applause]
he his boss
Audrey's day the manager instead
of dating the employee the handsome man
smooth probably don't build nothing
current boyfriend got mad cows at risk
every time he fingers